[Aplausos]
[Música]
a realizar aquí he la tuya que han
acatado en pizza a sumar una línea ni
chapa chance
guitarra o el ico citado joven y
compleja cat hasta se cansa catec suníes
ata o caja suma agua kiss tatarak iguana
y paja q pena caja lunes a hoja planea
camisas a he was a casa para marinista y
una casa marcan a casa
captada en el caja es que igual que ser
igual
buenas noches a todos estoy muy contenta
pero sobre todo emocionada de poder
estar con todos ustedes quienes nos
están acompañando en las distintas
plataformas digitales de esta actividad
quiero iniciar contándoles en la lengua
aymara
parte de mi historia de mi infancia que
tenía en puno por supuesto en la foto
que podemos apreciar es mi mamá y la
otra foto es una niña con una polera
verde que está en el campo track para
chanza y la tuya caracas jaua casi en
este la cama guapa machaca en la marca o
hits anza y una pampa chakana hijos esa
arena así saúco mouse y la white
papá maneja zapata ua sumará quizá jalón
otra seña hao y wampis haya pompis has
arena cañas así o canasta antes es
carácter con hamás a 80 chilena casa
naro jaimar eeuu está aquí y artista
with aimar ataque abuelito hay cajas ti
aunque ya esté castle ya no está aquí ua
argento
le toca con hamás salah ja ja machac
para chance a jan hus está tan a casa
hawai y un empate ansa camisas hay una
cancha de energía guasa hawks aceptan
haciendo una glosa contaba esa niña que
corría por el campo escalando por los
cerros pastando los animales estando en
la chacra esa niña fui yo crecí en una
comunidad en el centro poblado cama acá
ni en el distrito de platería en la
provincia de puno sin embargo también de
parte de mis papás es del distrito de
acora y es una de las vestimentas que en
este momento llevo puesto de los
chacareros de carita maya en ese
entonces hacía este
espacio este comentario de esta parte
porque esencialmente estudia el inicial
la primaria en una comunidad pero
posteriormente por esta misma mirada
visión de nuestros padres que quiere que
seamos profesionales y esa mirada de ir
a nuestra a la ciudad y no quedarnos en
la comunidad como suele decirse me fui a
la secundaria a estudiar hasta el 0 a 1
sin embargo en este tiempo pasó algo
inesperado que jamás me lo imaginé que
yo no lo espere un problema familiar en
caso de mi mamá se enfermó fue una
situación que me marcó la vida sin
embargo al terminar la secundaria
aparece un momento muy esperado que yo
no lo tampoco le espere porque vinieron
los especialistas del programa beck y
nos dieron a conocer sobre las distintas
carreras que había
en estas universidades públicas privadas
entonces decidí
estudiar la carrera de educación porque
les conté a mis papás como les
mencionaba esta parte de poder acceder a
la beca 18
tenía que elegir una carrera a la que yo
pues siempre tuve desde vocación de niña
en ese entonces estando en esta en esa
situación yo le conté a mis padres de
que quería postular a esta beca sin
embargo ellos no me tomaron atención
porque estaba este tema de salud que mi
mamá está en proceso de recuperación es
algo que me marcó la vida porque les
cuento esta parte porque yo sé que
muchos de ustedes que nos están
acompañando de las distintas plataformas
digitales se identificarán de crecer así
en el campo sin embargo cuando ya
postulé pase este proceso de la beca
haciendo un contexto yo del centro
poblado que soy de acá mccann y en el
tiempo de lluvia porque son dos tiempos
en la cosmovisión en los pueblos en el
pueblo aymara tenemos que trasladarnos a
otra comunidad porque la convivencia que
nosotros tenemos con la pachamama es
mutua es recíproca entonces nosotros al
trasladarnos a una comunidad donde no
hay energía donde no hay agua y desagüe
recuerdo que fui a la comunidad chutan y
en este caso una localidad pequeña una
chocita con los animales una caminata de
tres horas esto lo cuento porque ya para
venirme un día a lima para estudiar la
carrera que elegí
tenía que regresar tenía un celular de
teclas mi mamá me fui a vivir con mi
abuelita y tenía que rezar no no me
despedí de mi abuelito porque
en este desvinculó familiar que uno
tiene en ese momento es tan complejo
difícil de poder alejarnos de la familia
y muchos de seguro que ustedes están
escuchándome se identificarán de poder
perseguir estos sueños que nosotros
tenemos porque después de regresar estas
tres horas
empezó a caer relámpagos truenos
y nosotros en la comunidad sabemos que
no tenemos que tener estos aparatos
electrónicos porque puede suceder una
incidencia
entonces junto con mi mamá junto con mi
papá regresamos caminamos más de tres
horas
por supuesto con mucho miedo llorando
porque lo recuerdo porque así como estas
situaciones aún en pleno siglo 21
existen estas deficiencias
existen estas necesidades en nuestros
pueblos originarios donde
lamentablemente muchos niños no pueden
acceder a la educación no pueden no
tienen todos los elementos para
continuar en la educación que ellos
quieren en ese entonces regrese triste
ese día no podía dormir pensando por lo
que me iba a alejar de mis padres
entonces ese día pasó espere el día que
tenía que viajar a lima y recuerdo que
llegue un primero de mayo a la ciudad de
lima con muchos temores no así como me
están viendo en este momento con la
vestimenta puesta llegué con un jean con
una polera con esa vestimenta común que
nosotros lo decimos y recuerdo muchísimo
el momento cuando mis compañeros del
pueblo originario shipibo conibo
hablaban en su lengua originaria
hablaban en shipibo conibo y nosotros
entre nosotros nos mirábamos y decíamos
están hablando en su lengua materna y
nosotros estamos hablando en castellano
como si nosotros solos había solo
sabemos la lengua castellano pero
teníamos en nosotros mismos la lengua la
cultura pero que teníamos escondidos
dentro de nosotros
pasó en los primeros días de la carrera
los primeros días del semestre y porque
esta parte marcó en mi historia en mi
vida porque una de las maestras nos
preguntó quién eres
quién soy y les invito a cada uno de
ustedes a preguntarse quiénes somos
somos brisaida luis josemaría o tenemos
algo dentro de nosotros que aún no está
floreciendo que aún no estamos
recolectando nuestras raíces fue una
pregunta que pareciera ser fácil es sin
embargo te re preguntas y te preguntas
quiénes son tus abuelos quiénes son tus
abuelos maternos y paternos de dónde
eres si bien es cierto naciste en lima
pero tus abuelos tus padres son de una
región y en cada región en cada
comunidad hay una forma de vida así como
yo les conté de las distintas
actividades que se crece que se vive en
la comunidad
entonces nuevamente
le repreguntó esta pregunta me preguntó
y yo esencialmente respondí que soy
brisaida pero que también tengo la
lengua originaria que poco a poco iba
aprendiendo que poco a poco iba
avanzando la lengua terminó el semestre
y yo regresé a mi comunidad hablando en
la lengua aymara porque ya era un
proceso la primera etapa de mi etapa
universitaria
regresé hablando recuerdo muy bien que
al llegar a mi comunidad les hablaba en
aymara y saben que se preguntaban las
personas y decía estás regresando de la
ciudad de lima pero muchos al regresar
de una ciudad de dónde son que a veces
no se reconocen y nos saludan muchas
veces aculturados y también recuerdo que
a una de las señoritas de mi comunidad
le hablo en aymara camisa aquí cuya cuna
cloradas atrás
y la respuesta usualmente es entiendo
pero no no hablo es la misma entonces
sabía que nuevamente trabajar y para
regresarme ya lima ya no quería regresar
porque este vínculo familiar que tienes
con con la familia había que
que fue un difícil pero recuerdo
muchísimo lo que mi mamá me dijo y decía
como a todos que imagino que les dice no
estás yendo a trabajar está siendo
estudiar y tienes todo el apoyo tienes
todo el apoyo y deberías de saber
aprovechar ese momento y verdaderamente
la asumí con ojos llorando pero regrese
así y porque les cuento esto porque a
veces es tan difícil identificarnos y
decir cómo llegó a reconectar me con las
raíces de mis abuelos con las raíces de
mis padres con esta forma de vida con
esta forma de conocimiento que tenemos
en nuestras comunidades desde la
artesanía desde la comida desde las
danzas la historia la tradición oral y
llegó el momento
de que yo como estudiante en ese
entonces tenía que representar
al pueblo aymara es decir nosotros en la
universidad éramos de tres pueblos
originarios quechuas aymaras y shipibos
con ellos yo tenía que representar a
este grupo de mis compañeros lo tenía la
lengua yo me sentía firmada de mí misma
me sentía bien con la lengua de que fue
algo mío que lo estaba dejando de lado
hacía falta
algo que a mí me faltaba y es por eso
que en este momento también estoy con la
vestimenta pensé me falta algo y
necesito que hace para que yo me pueda
sentir que soy aymara y que esté
representando a este grupo de mis
compañeros
fue todo un proceso para que yo vista la
vestimenta por ejemplo el día de hoy
saliendo del trabajo yo me vine en el
metropolitano entonces fue un proceso
porque llevaba en mi mochila y les
cuento así llevaba mi mochila la ropa
que tengo puesto al llegar a la
actividad que se estaba realizando
llegaba y me la cambiaba
terminaba la actividad de la sacaba y el
regresado a mi cuarto pero llegó un
momento de decir que yo soy aymara
de por qué tengo que sentir estos miedos
que muchas veces nosotros los tenemos
aún dentro de nosotros miedo por hablar
en nuestra lengua originaria miedo
porque no queremos vestirnos la
vestimenta en nuestras comunidades por
el temor a que tengamos discriminación
del otro de la otra persona con quien
muchas veces no lo es correcto decir el
otro porque aún seguimos pensando en
ello del otro pueblo originario
muchas veces
haciendo un hincapié de lo que les
comentaba en la primera parte las
lenguas originarias
usualmente por ésta por este crecimiento
de la globalización es que nuestras
lenguas originarias se siguen opacando
fue este proceso de que a mí me ayudó a
decir que soy aymara y de que en
distintos espacios puedo mostrarme como
soy con la vestimenta con nuestra lengua
con nuestra lengua originaria de la que
nosotros nos caracterizamos de nuestros
pueblos de nuestros padres
entonces nuevamente
mencionó este este proceso que tuve que
pasar
simplemente por estos miedos que muchas
veces decimos
muchas veces
haciendo un hincapié de lo que les conté
en el inicial o primaria que
lamentablemente está desvinculado de
nuestra cultura de nuestra lengua y que
tenemos otros horizontes otras miradas
de no responder a estas necesidades ese
día que yo les conté que fue tan difícil
para mí recordar y hasta ahora lo
recuerdo es bonito estar en la comunidad
esta convivencia que tenemos con la
pachamama sin embargo hay muchísimas
necesidades y una de las necesidades es
trabajar por esta afirmación identitaria
en los niños de poder responder estas
necesidades que se tienen en las
comunidades que aún persisten y nadie
nos puede dejar de negar que en plena
pandemia
en el centro de salud en la educación
faltaba muchísimo que trabajar y falta
muchísimo que trabajar
por eso porque es importante para
nosotros nuestra lengua que no se nos
identifica en nuestra identidad el
sentirnos
en empoderadas en distintos espacios
porque esencialmente nuestra lengua no
solo es una lengua si bien es cierto es
una forma de interacción sin embargo
tiene todo un conocimiento historia
tradición oral
conocimientos muy profundos de nuestras
comunidades
esencialmente los valores el saber
escucharnos el saber ayudarnos
hace que esto para nosotros es muy
importante
reconocer estos valores estos
conocimientos de nuestros pueblos es
llevarlo a la acción porque es el legado
de nuestros abuelos
y además
de todo este conocimiento nos permite
acercarnos a una comunidad de la
específica a una comunidad donde tiene
una forma de conocimiento un modo de
vida
por tanto nosotros preguntándonos
quiénes somos desde las distintas
carreras que estamos estudiando miremos
a estas necesidades
miremos a poder responder derechos
lingüísticos de nuestras comunidades
responder necesidades primero
preguntándote quién eres
sintiéndote orgulloso de dónde eres de
tu comunidad y llevar en alto la
comunidad donde tú perteneces a tus
padres a tus abuelos porque esto que tú
ya te identificas te te ayudará a poder
comprender al otro
a la otra persona que está en el costado
tuyo en tu trabajo en tu estudio en el
pequeño espacio que tú te encuentres
porque el ser empático es también
conocer esta cultura esta forma de vida
que tiene una comunidad distinta a la
tuya y efectivamente no queremos más
discriminación porque queremos seguir
aprendiendo de la otra comunidad porque
somos 55 pueblos originarios y 48
lenguas originarias y teniendo esta
respuesta a nosotros mismos y de sobre
todo ayudar a los demás ayudaremos a
responder estas necesidades que muchas
veces no es respondida por nosotros
mismos
porque si tenemos una mirada y muchas
veces hablamos de esta interculturalidad
de esta relación de entre culturas pero
muchas veces no vamos a una
interculturalidad
transformativa se queda en políticas
hablamos pero no llevamos a la acción
necesitamos urgentemente que entre
nosotros nos escuchemos
entre nosotros nos ayudemos
más allá de subrayar una política que si
efectivamente lo es
necesitamos
ayudarnos entre nosotros
reconocer y para todos los hermanos que
me están viendo que aún quizás están
mencionando de que sea hablar pero
perdón entiendo pero no hablo o tienen
esta iniciativa el trabajo está en
nosotros
el trabajo está en todos de todos los
actores padres de familia
abuelos niños porque la transmisión es
intergeneracional
si nosotros no lo hacemos mañana no
habrá quien lo hace por eso es que todos
tenemos que aportar con un granito de
arena para que nuestra lengua siga
creciendo para que nuestra lengua siga
fortaleciendo y no llegar a escenarios
lingüísticos donde muchas veces es de
revitalización es decir que están
haciendo planes para que nuestra lengua
siga viva porque más allá de una lengua
que es una forma de interacción es una
cultura viva es una forma de vida
en pleno siglo 21 todos estamos
conectados en las redes y también es uno
de nuestros roles como hablantes de una
lengua originaria como jóvenes de
comunicarnos en las redes sociales
de estar en espacios más amplios y ser
conscientes de lo que estamos hablando
hablemos del día a día en casa en el
espacio donde nos encontramos pero sobre
todo como estudiantes desde las
universidades tengamos una mirada
intercultural para responder a esta
afirmación identitaria a esta afirmación
que muchas veces estamos escondiendo aún
no estamos floreciendo aún lo tenemos
ocultado en nosotros porque quizás no
nos hemos preguntado esa pregunta tan
fácil que parece quién somos quién eres
quién soy más allá de tener un nombre
y por eso quiero terminar con esta frase
que para poder amar a la madre tierra'
debemos de saber de dónde venimos
porque el vientre es nuestro primer
territorio de reconocer a nuestra
familia de reconocer de dónde es de
dónde venimos para poder contribuir y
responder a las necesidades que vemos
desde las distintas carreras que somos
contribuir al fortalecimiento de nuestra
diversidad cultural y lingüística no
usar a un país con una comunicación
intercultural con una mirada
pluricultural esta mirada diversa que
tenemos y nuestro trabajo es seguir
fortalecido desde donde nos encontramos
y eso que quede en cada uno de nosotros
el granito de arena que estamos
aportando para que nuestras lenguas
sigan creciendo sigan fortaleciendo pero
sobre todo será el orgullo para nosotros
de que esta lengua la lengua que
nosotros manejamos nuestros niños
quienes vivan que sigan
preservando las que sigan fortaleciendo
y las culiacán acá
un cambio una hija tú eres quien la que
pone taponeros chapa chanza fallaste
hasta que usara hawai o cat pizza para
mainero simon apps maja se cansa caubet
paisaje guasa jajó tatana o cantas ypf
apolinar y guasas a puro dolor mañana
contiguas a jal un año durán asado hanyu
y nama ya arzu cañas a quiet mira la
esquina que pone cuales están muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]